welcome to this video playing
international master key god what's the
name Kim oh my kids are me okay
so let's see what he's coming up with
only 96 yeah recently there was a book
released on that even caught what was it
called The Dark Knight system or
something like that so quite interesting
only 96 ok I played a rather restrained
fashion here just making solid moves at
one point he probably plays d5 him 95 e
5 of course
okay so let's um keep it simple and
exchange yeah this was probably not
putting much fear and into black but
some fairly solid setup
yeah he unfortunately has not played c6
and he very likely will not do that
would be a big positional mistake so
what what are my plans iam is not easy
I would like to exchange this maybe I
can play this and Bishop c4 yeah maybe
at least I played it quickly but sure
that it's really great but it was a lie
quick move theoretically speaking I
could play Bishop h6 but this is my good
Bishop and the g7 Bishop is not
particularly great so this is something
I won't do yes
yeah I thought about that this is a
simple response asking my rook yeah
where do you go Jim I could go to go
here yeah this is a problem I don't I
don't really want to play f3 this would
weaken the dark squares and non sleep
maybe you set up the spin I really like
to get in Bishop Bishop to c4 maybe I
can play Queen e3 next covering this
pawn and then Bishop c4 now it's not a
great position
maybe Queen before even yeah this is
also on
and I cannot take you for at the moment
but yeah maybe even as Queen before okay
I could before I can maybe take on f6
not that this is too too great but at
least it's playable okay the pressure on
e4 is becoming a bit - a bit too
problematic
I know it's even that Bishop e7 um it's
not nice
yeah the whole setup that I chose here
was probably just an just bad
yeah good good choices now in a bishop
c-5m you should be for was also a
possibility
so at least I can get this Bishop to c4
okay so he allows the exchange
shin-young that some simply simply
better for black this position
yeah but not much I can do about it
check he doesn't need to take but let's
get this pre moving yeah saw that but
what what was what what what was I
supposed to do it's um I cannot even go
look on the third-ranked
to get some counter play against f7 that
is really a bad position
Oh
yeah the only slight hope is of course
the opposite colored bishops and it's a
very slight hope maybe we should be 43
something like that
you know I'm threatening h4
check look at six
hmm this is probably a draw but maybe
can I can I do something here this King
is a bit a bit off him maybe I can can
can be a bit more ambitious even now
came okay let's do that this is a draw
how to do this in the most precise way
no it's probably not really measuring I
can also just just go here now can go to
g5 just the easiest you know just just
go to a to say here yeah yeah this is
just a fortress no you just I'm just
moving the bishop morale Alfred yeah
okay and this he should have won of
course yeah I played this rather
unambitious opening and then when go got
into position where I just didn't have
any idea probably should have played
Bishop somewhere around here probably
should have played Bishop C form to get
this Bishop activated at least once once
it would came to that I'm already a bit
a bit worse I just played this too yeah
you know that didn't I didn't
you think did it led to led to big
trouble early this is a good regroup a
apprentice he played this really well I
cannot play f3 here this is so ugly so
this is why I went here okay now he's
got the bishops but I hope to to get at
least um you should see foreign but
blankets of course and in excellent
shape him yang yeah yeah this is
probably necessary I don't think I have
something else to release some of the
pressure around him yeah I can he can
win the second pawn and he did and okay
this is lost but somehow he he allowed a
bit of counter play f6 really was was a
bit strange
or at least here he needs to do
something else in here also I have rook
f6 oops
just put it back sorry to do this to
show look f6 yeah also look f-16 if this
should be a draw as well but I already
got ambitious here jack yeah this is
this is also drawn okay yes check here's
this check this is maybe a problem I
know it's still a draw once he gets to
c3 I take only for that but this is this
is a bit tricky this is some before
check before check is the problem maybe
I should I should do something else 'i'm
not take okay but i could also play here
and this wasn't bad and yeah but after
Bishop a5 i only had this and this is
really a trophy
first the Queen side is is frozen and
then this Bishop is is an excellent
locator
yanti I can and just stay and the King
is blocking the pond and he can they
cannot even attack him once he attacks
on my Bishop captures and protects on c2
all right
so not a great game that it shows that
even very bad position sometimes I'm
with opposite colored bishops have some
drawing chances thanks for watching